I want to bring something up and maybe
you heard about this has bit of a news
story the music and life of the late
rapper Tupac Shakur is about to be
turned into a Broadway musical it's true
yeah it's called holler if you hear me
it's already in pre-production they're
getting ready to bring it to the stage
now some people have been saying this is
odd to combine hip-hop with Broadway
musical theater these two don't go
together
but apparently this is gonna be a new
trend there are already several other
Broadway musicals being developed all
based on the lives of other rap music
legends and we're the only show that has
a sneak preview of some of these
musicals we're so lucky we're so lucky I
don't know how we got this privileged ya
know when you think Broadway theater or
rap you think coned right sure
first up soon to open at the Helen Hayes
theater please enjoys a terrific new
musical called Big Pimpin the life and
music of jay-z
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we got two left feet I feel bad for you
son I got 99 problems with dancing
[Music]
very gritty yeah it really felt like
that was jay-z
up next is a musical opening soon at the
Gershwin Theatre which celebrates the
career of Snoop Dogg give it up for
ain't nothing but a g-sharp how can i
rap like you professor dog it's really
very easy you just need a double CC and
then another L and then B because with
is in the middle it makes every symptom
system and soon you'll be rapping I'm
not sure I understand you see first you
take an easel you dribble it with sizzle
out of - of nizzle and you're done so my
mother is my middle and my father is my
bizzle
and I like to eat bananas and wash them
down like a potato
my chisel I think she's got
[Music]
that shows going all the way oh yeah
finally premiering soon of the majestic
theatre put your hands together for
Vanilla Ice American legend baby you're
a nice white baby and we don't mean
maybe when we say someday you'll be the
greatest rap
[Music]
[Applause]
here give it up for
[Applause]
[Music]